The Joe Rogan Experience are the
comments are like so brave
we're sitting there going are we the
only ones laughing at this I gotta say
in your mom's house and in the Garth
Brooks comments sometimes the comments
are like to me like a little comedy
break from life I like to go when Garth
Brook posts something and then I go and
see your mom's house fans have bombarded
the comments like where are the bodies
follow them everywhere now and then
Facebook everything they're they're
making jokes inside like jeans high and
tight confessed for the murder of my
auntie
oh my God confess for the murderer my
aunt G your DNA was at the crime I can't
find jet poo because he's [ __ ] on a
plane yeah he [ __ ] on a plane yeah
what do you mean somebody who works at
the FBO in Nashville sent an image from
they're like we clean Jets we clean
Garth Jet and somebody [ __ ] all
the next week they're like I got fired
so we read it shut the [ __ ] up and then
they uh seems like a violation of some
NDA yeah yeah
they were saying that they said that
that um they're not really good about
paying the they don't like to pay a lot
of the bills for like the maintenance
and then he was like no he does pay he
does pay dude the best is nadav and uh I
don't know who else it was yeah they got
into a can I what they got into a Garth
Brooks oh concert that was amazing and
they got on the big screen the Jumbotron
at Houston Texas Holding aside this is
where are the bodies where are the
bodies G and then it's on the thing and
then it just cuts away from it yeah
because he dropped he dropped the sign
would you be willing to drop this if
Garth Brooks would come on the podcast
100. for sure
why would that never happen Garth gosh
that [ __ ] happens oh here it is a job
you're a genius yes got Garth you should
make this happen and then for everybody
we love you where are the bodies G
look how quickly they pulled that camera
away they didn't just switch cameras
they backed out of it yeah they did see
how they backed out like [ __ ] wait what
is that oh [ __ ] but wait yeah
there's no benefit for Garth to go on
the podcast
first of all they're very nice people
both Tom and Christina are very nice
people
shut the [ __ ] up for a second and they'd
be happy
to have Garth on and be nice to him
explain we're sorry if this hurt your
feelings this is all just fun yes
was like listen man I can't have that
[ __ ] come up we're two years away from a
statue of limitations what do you mean
no why not 100 no why if your garden
I'll tell you as I'll tell you as Garth
yeah uh
how many months do you think it happened
to Garth where it was a problem where he
was like the [ __ ] is this never all of
them right right actually we got so we
got first we would go like do you think
Garth knows we'd talk about that and
then I happened to meet somebody
who actually is closely connected to him
and that happens to be a fan of mine
and I met this person and I go so what's
going on like does he know and he goes
oh yeah he knows of course and then I go
so what's the deal and they go well
he goes I asked his right hand person
uh
does Garth hate Tom
and the guy goes Garth doesn't hate
anybody which is such a Garth answer a
girl doesn't hate anybody because you
were just like no right but what is it
just it just that like they're just
accept that it's they have a spin on it
that they're like you know when you're
big when you really well know you have a
big profile yeah you can't control what
happens online and all this stuff but
it's all his it's all the comments it's
not like it's every post it's every post
but if you went on your podcast I think
it would turn around
no no no no no
I'll tell you what I'll tell you what
I'm gonna I'm gonna be are you guys
ready to let him talk for a second
because no it's sister it's birthday
yeah yeah I think so did you shut him up
now and then you'll shut me up but
nothing benefits
there's nothing that benefits Garth now
I'm just being real obviously
it's bigger for Tom than it is for
Gardens here's why I disagree here's why
I disagree so we have profiled people
that we've made fun of but 4 and there's
a handful of them that leaned into it
yeah like they were like we a dude's
dating video that we profile we make fun
of and then he's like hey I'm the guy
and everybody who's making fun of them
goes oh like he's cool you're owning
that you made this terrible dating video
and then it becomes like basically they
become all fans of this guy and I think
if he were to show a sense of humor what
would God ever do to y'all okay he would
I think it would actually change people
would flip out objection you're talking
about I'm just being yes yes you know
I'm your best friend I'm not just talk
just go ahead
you're talking about the guy's dating
video Yeah versus Garth Brooks yeah yeah
who's selling out stadiums yeah he
already has the fans I know he does but
it's like it's like Wayne Brady leaning
into like I'm a Gangster nope it's not
it's not no it's you're talking about
you're talking about you're talking
about there
who in in all respects is kind of
trolling a star
it's like if I if it's you know I'm just
being honest about it it's because
I think I think what actually happens
this is my just opinion I think it was
actually a bird over here I think what
the [ __ ] going on I thought about this
before by the look I've thought about
this ton oh I think what's over here I
think it would make Garth Brooks more
money to be on my podcast
but like I think whatever happened and
his fans aren't watching you know your
mom's house the comments change I think
what happens is he starts getting a
bunch of instead of like these things
that make no sense they're all start
going like if he doesn't like the
comments the comments go away because of
this I do I think so but but as a person
who's been
a victim of Tom's comments because you
[ __ ] dogs or or the worst one the
worst ones don't even was when my
special came out uh secret time and we
were and Tom was calling me the biggest
American racist in the world and and I
was watching it happen in the comments
and it was like it was like I wish I
could watch this but he's a racist and
then to watch the confusion that happens
that's the problem is the confusion that
happens is what makes you feel powerless
is when someone's trolling you but
that's happening now but the confusion
is where garth's fans aren't
but if they're in the comments and they
see all this craziness that they don't
understand at all and it's all where
they don't understand it because
he ain't Killed Nobody But but if he
does kill a man this is how my car did
it good then he killed a man because
they deserved it and it's okay to kill a
black that's the way that's the way
these comments are coming out where the
[ __ ] wow because I watched them they
might not even be real comments they'll
be Russian troll Farms they could
commenting they uh at that concert that
Zolo went to he held up that sign he uh
they interviewed people outside the
concert and they're like what do you
think of these uh oh my conversations
and now it was on like one of the live
shows but it had all these people go
like uh some people were like what are
you talking about what is that and then
some of them were like well you know I'm
a fan of the music if he kills
somebody's yeah
that is of sound mind that would go like
you should definitely go on your mom's
disagree if you just like the comments
they go away with that Garth I'm a fan I
would have never done what Tom's done
but I need you to know that it's gonna
be okay and if you go on your mom's
house we'll clear everything up